[Musique]
donc je répète la situation actuellement
estimations ou rtf sofres valéry giscard
d'estaing 50,9 françois mitterrand 49,1
estimations honeywell giscard 51
mitterrand 49 ifop pas de possibilité de
sortir une estimation à l'heure actuelle
comment ces chiffres ont ils été
accueilli aux différents pc aux
différents quartiers généraux des deux
principaux candidats celui de monsieur
valéry giscard d'estaing d'abord rue de
la bienfaisance
non
la bienfaisance la rue de la
bienfaisance a été barrée à la
circulation
et cette foule que vous pouvez voir
quelques centaines de personnes se
trouvent face aux 41 au numéro 41 17 rue
de la bienfaisance où ont été installés
les récepteurs de télévision à
l'extérieur une foule plutôt jeune on
distingue dans certains endroits des
maillots giscard à la barre ce sont les
supporters de valéry giscard d'estaing
qui pour beaucoup d'entre eux sont là
depuis assez longtemps déjà les
résultats
voilà ça s'était plutôt c'était plutôt
le l'autre le quartier général de
monsieur mitterrand est ce que on peut
la voir à l'antenne louis non seulement
une déclaration de monsieur françois
mitterrand qui est pour l'instant à
château chinon mais qui pourrait venir
dans la soirée à la tour montparnasse
pour suivre cette soirée est bien en
dehors des journalistes il y aura 500
invités qui ont qui viendront écouter
aussi françois mitterrand mais je dois
vous dire que bien sûr dans les bureaux
je suppose qu'il ya un peu de déception
chez les collaborateurs de monsieur
françois mitterrand merci c'était pire
chantier au pc de monsieur françois
mitterrand
[Musique]